asian americans study twice as many
hours as the average american
it's impossible to control all of the
circumstances in which you are
never discriminated against for
something there is this notion
that asians are smarter than everybody
else
actually you are a racist even though
you don't think you are a racist you are
racist because you're participating
in a racist structure i wasn't
interested in harvard
if harvard did not discriminate against
asian americans
asians would make up about 43 of harvard
student body
it doesn't matter if you check or
uncheck the box asian or not
doesn't matter harvard's going to know
what race you are because they believe
that whites are the
privileged race in america they're the
powerful race
can we provide enough opportunity for
the people who are less privileged
[Music]
my guest today is very comfortable
pushing the envelope he's also the
author of a book called an inconvenient
minority the
attack on asian american excellence and
the fight for
meritocracy kenny shu thank you so much
for being on valuetainment
thank you so much patrick i appreciate
it so listen i gotta tell you your
uh uh your your position and story is
kind of confusing some people because
it's supposed to be the other way around
yet you're challenging the envelope
with the fact that harvard is not
necessarily
accepting as many asian students because
their grades are way too good and
they're trying to
you know balance themselves out so they
can take a little bit of everybody and
not necessarily the best students but as
long as they fit this
criteria they're open to so i'm actually
curious to go into this with you here
but
prior to actually getting into some of
your positions do you mind taking a
second here and
sharing your background with the
audience
i'm second generation i was born in
america i was born in maryland
my parents are chinese immigrants my dad
was an entrepreneur
started his own small business he was
doing a little was doing well
then the recession hit so we had to fold
it worked for corporate a little bit
but i was always raised you know valuing
hard work
and above all my dad always told me
don't be lazy and if you choose
something whatever you choose to do
kenny
do your best try your best and be the
best
so i decided i went to college
i was a math major but i was
always a writer i always loved writing i
wrote fiction when i was little
and this harvard case got into the
national press
and i knew this from my own experience
that harvard was obviously
discriminating against asian americans
but
i was mad about it but i didn't think i
would write a book about it
until i saw that this ideology is
spreading
throughout the entire rest of the
country in every equity program
every college now even in businesses
people are coming up with diversity
equity and inclusion
and all i see is a penalization of the
meritocratic spirit of this country that
made it great
you tell me i had to write a book about
it and uh it just came out july 13th
and it's been doing really great and so
i'm really excited to talk about that
story in my book
yeah so why why do you think that has
happened what's the motive behind it
why harvard discriminates against asian
americans because
harvard uh they really want
a racially specifically a racially
diverse class so they see asians
overrepresented right because if harvard
did not discriminate against asian
americans asians would make up about 43
percent of harvard student body based on
merit alone based on grades test scores
so what they do is that they
artificially lower that to about half
asian americans only to less than half
asian americans make up about 20
of harvard's student body um because
harvard wants to admit more people of
diverse races and they think it makes
them more virtuous
okay so so let's go through this so 43
would be the student body asians if it
was basic based on merits but it's not
it's currently 20
and if we look at the uh based on
national population i think asians make
up 5.9 percent
yeah america give or take blacks are
13.4 hispanics are about 18 and a half
then you got the whites who are the
non-hispanic whites are a little over 60
and you got a small percentage of middle
easterns and others like myself that
make up the rest of the percentage right
so why is it why is it help me
understand this part
why is it that the population is only
5.9
asian yet based on the criteria's
43 would be in harvard
that's 5.9 to 43 why is that what are
the asian
families doing differently than the rest
of us they
are teaching values that get a good
educational excellence so
asian americans study twice as many
hours as the average american
right they they study about 15 hours a
week the average american studies about
seven um asian americans
tend to prioritize academic excellence
because they have to because you come to
this country and you don't have
generational wealth you don't have
privilege you don't have social
connections
how are you going to move up in society
how are you going to provide a better
future for your
for your kids well it has to be through
education because that's the great lever
forward in asian american culture they
really prioritize
the valuing of of education especially
chinese and chinese chinese-centered um
cultures um it's it's pretty much baked
into
you know the the confucian system in
some way the the ancient old tradition
um and uh and as a result you know
and the other thing that asians do is
that they have better two-parent family
structures that allow them to provide a
conducive
environment for academic excellence uh
because you can have a
you know uh you don't your parent can
pay more attention to the child and
that's very much valued in the culture
so that's what begets the academic
excellence part
got it so when i was in uh when i was in
high school and
we would have friends who were asian and
you know you know
whatever they may be the students middle
eastern students were also doing very
good in school because in iran it's also
when you come to america you know
they value education a lot and to them
math
some of the math we would take in that
they teach here in seventh grade we
would learn in fourth grade it was
always hey i already know this stuff i
learned this stuff years ago this is
easy stuff why are we doing this
i've done this for many many years but
the question i'm asking you if we can go
a little bit deeper so
somebody would say well look at that guy
that guy's the curve of the class he's
at 98
and we got to beat him because he's 100
of the class oh because he's asians you
know they got genetics they have the
certain genes and
you know they're smarter than everybody
else so there is this notion
that asians are smarter than everybody
else but
we don't hear about the 15 hours of
studying per week which is twice as much
as everybody else so
you said the uh dual family husband and
wife you know mom and dad stayed
together there
great what other values did you learn
from your dad i know you gave a couple
of them to us here
you know don't be lazy do your best
whatever you're doing give your best etc
etc
what standards and expectation was it to
be in the shoe family what were some of
the standards and expectations
yeah how do you yeah um well how do you
get to be the smartest in the class
right you you have to
you know my dad and my mom and for many
chinese-american korean-american
vietnamese-american families
a lot of this is a lot of this is very
similar
um you you have a you have a certain
role in the family right your role
is you know and i talk about this in my
book an inconvenient minority your role
is you need to be academically excellent
you know you need to to study hard
and one of this i'll tell you i'll give
you the example of math
okay so you you're given a problem set
or a problem sheet you know at an early
age
and maybe you need to memorize a
multiplication table and you do problems
um
in in our family you know if you didn't
do it right
um nobody's gonna punish you okay or
anything like that but you just gotta
keep doing it until you get it right
you know you gotta keep doing until you
get it right you gotta practice
you gotta push forward um asian
americans really believe that math
is just a sport of it's just a sport of
practice and practice and continuing to
do things
over and over again it's math is not
really that complicated
you know it's funny that people like to
say oh i'm not a math person or anything
like that
asian americans don't really believe
that you know you you can't
it doesn't matter if you're not a math
person you can do math and you can
achieve at a high level
my inherent interest wasn't even in math
my inherent interest was in writing i
was a writer
i was uniquely talented at writing and
yet i was a math major
in college because i was pushed from an
early age
to just work hard on problems think
creatively think abstractly
and just most of all if i get stuck
to finish it to to get unstuck to do to
do the best i can
to get it done how do they hold you
accountable was it
was one of those did one of your parents
was it involved in it was it something
where hey
here let's do the math problem together
or go figure it out on your own and then
come and bring the homework to me
what style is the accountability with
parents well i mean it's different
styles
my family you know was was more
hands-off for me
i did a lot of problem sets i did
honestly i did a lot of
i did a lot of just learning from
textbooks i just studied textbooks i
would i would do it for
for an hour it's like the resources are
all here they're all there
you know you can learn from textbooks
and textbooks can teach you a lot if you
actually
put your nose in the textbook and
actually try to learn from it
i saw a statistic in china that said the
average parent sp and spends uh
18 of their income on kids after school
program not even private schooling or
education just
after school program what other ways did
you have your parents invest into you
to learn did they invest into tutors was
there additional courses you took what
what other ways did it invest into you
becoming a better student
there is some enrichment um i don't
think the enrichment
the the after school like i did i did
some like after school camps
a lot of those camps are just fun fun
camps got it um i don't think that those
are the primary cause of
of of what drove me to get better at
math i really think it was just putting
my nose in a textbook
and learning from that what what was the
currency in your house that got your mom
and dad to say yes to you
i had to be assertive i'd be assertive
my mom and dad were a little bit
different
than than than a simple traditional
chinese-american parent because
my dad was you know wanted to assimilate
into this country and in this country
you know it's a quarterback country you
have to be assertive you have to assert
yourself
so uh i did have to ask for what i
wanted
and i had to articulate it and i had to
communicate it so that made me better as
a communicator yeah so you know the
whole book uh what is a tiger uh uh
uh the battle hymn of the tiger mother i
don't know what was the name of that
book
yeah yeah that went viral and you know
she got both criticism
and she got a lot of uh uh from one side
it's like yeah that's pretty intense
that parents like that and the other
side is wait that's a
you know new like a sweatshop you're
working your tail off you're expected to
do so much oh my god who wants to have
you know so what do you say to the
criticism of an
extremely high demanding discipline
expectation type of an environment to
raise your kids
where nowadays you'll read many articles
saying it's better to not put that kind
of expectation on your kids
on how they perform because it can
produce a high level of anxiety
and panic attack on your kids it's not
the right way to do it what do you say
to that well first of all
the the idea that today's comfort
parenting
uh today's comfort parenting is a modern
liberal society
uh practice it's not it's not practiced
by all cultures you know the idea that
you should just
you know train your kid to you know be
special and he's special and everything
like that i don't think most parents
believe that in the 17th century when
you're a substances farmer
right you have kids so they can help you
so they can work on the farm so they can
help you milk the cows or help you with
your trade
right um we're in a very rich society
and rich society
permits indulgent parenting um so
my parents parented out of scarcity not
indulgence
and a lot of that's what a lot of asian
parents do they parent out of the
mindset
that there are scarce resources in the
world and they don't really have time to
waste and one of those resources is time
so is the idea of parenting on
on the asian side and again keep in mind
it's very similar to middle eastern like
in my family
my mom god forbid found out how much
money i have and what my net worth is
and she said somebody told me you worth
this much money i said mom it's lies why
do you believe this stuff you know i'm
just a regular guy
and she'll see and she'll come and see
the businesses we build then
oh my gosh this is all the business and
then she'll say how come you don't have
a four-year degree
when are you going to get a bachelor's
degree you know so in the middle eastern
culture either a doctor
a lawyer or an engineer you do that oh
yeah you made it to the top right
you've done above and beyond but how do
parents in the asian community
view the role they play for their kids
and
is there anything of the kids on the
culture that you owe back to your
parents
or is the culture more my goal is to
raise you and you go live your life and
do whatever you do is there anything
that i get back
from my kids when they become adults
independent winning
okay so they they really viewed their
role
as as helping their kids to
not not helping their kids but
really pushing their kids to to have
value in this world to add to do
something that adds
significant value and and that leads to
respectability which is why you see a
lot of asian parents pushing their kids
into these respectable careers doctors
engineers
lawyers everything like that those are
all respectable those have degrees those
have
credence and the the the reason why they
do that
is because you know they come here
they have no status they have to earn
their way up
you know and what they crave for their
child is for their child to have a
better future than them and
future and professional careers are
aligned to them with a with a better
future because it's respectable it's
high status it's everything like that so
they will they will pour their hearts
into their child
they will pour everything they have in
their child
um you have these children in new york
so you have these parents in new york
city
who are literally like these chinese
parents in new york city who literally
don't even speak english who maybe are
working in a restaurant
maybe own their own place probably
making less than
you know thirty thousand dollars a year
and every penny that they have that they
save they put in their child's um
test prep they put in their child's
textbooks
you know they they try to do some
enrichment for their kid and that
that produces results their their kids
grow go up to uh
go into the gifted and talented programs
in new york city they graduate from
stuyvesant bronx science high school
where 90 of the kids who are on free
reduced lunch
in those high schools are asian so
that's the part where i was going when
you said there's a little bit of
enrichment you know that money the
mother is saving to help in the test
prep to help them get better scores on
the sats or whatever maybe that's pretty
pretty impressive to hear that by the
way i know you you did not go to harvard
you graduated from davidson college
magna laude is what you graduated
majoring in mathematics and minoring in
philosophy
what was your gpa in high school how
well did you do in high school oh i was
a
well i mean i i cheated a little bit
because i had a i took a bunch of ap
classes uh which i'm not sure if you
consider cheating but it's four point it
was like 4.4 something
out of five so at 4.4 out of 5
did you apply to go to harvard or no no
i never applied to go to harvard
uh i actually i applied to go to
princeton and then i think i applied to
go to
upenn wharton i think those are the two
ivy leagues that i applied to but we're
not interested in going to harvard what
you were not interested in harvard
i wasn't interested in harvard no why
not i think
well i knew that they won i knew that
they were discriminating against asians
so that there was kind of a moral
principled thing there but then i think
there was also kind of
uh i i didn't like
i didn't like the culture when i toured
there and everything like that i
never wanted to apply to all seven ivy
league colleges that was never my
intention got it so you didn't like the
culture
but you did go and take a look at the
campus to see if you were going to like
it or not and then you applied to
princeton now
would you say princeton runs a similar
kind of a philosophy as harvard to make
sure they please
every ethnicity as they're accepting
students or princeton goes on a
different philosophy
no it's the same philosophy the ivy
leagues have the same philosophy there's
there's this
graph in my book an inconvenient
minority it has
it has asian american percentage as a
percentage of student body for all seven
ivy leagues
and what happens is there's like an
initial spike in the 80s
and then by the 90s it goes down and
in every single ivy league school asians
are between like 15 and 18
of the student body every single one and
then you see
caltech which doesn't practice
discrimination against asian americans
and their asian population goes from
like 10
to like 40 percent you got to be kidding
me no i'm not kidding you
this is this graph is in the book so
every ivy league has the same ratio of
15 to 18 caltech's got 40 percent
yeah how much criticism does caltech get
uh for not practicing discrimination
against asian americans yeah
how much critic like how who is is
anybody targeting
caltech's approach and calling them you
know many different words that nowadays
are used to
you know defame the character of that
university no one's
uh really targeting caltech right now
because their reputation is so excellent
you know their their their their school
is like a sixth the size of mit
but they they're number five in the
world in terms of research papers
produced in the sciences and
mit is like number two believable yeah
is iit number one who's who's number one
is
number one okay so mit's number two
caltic as you said celtic is one-sixth
the size of mit yet they're sixth in
research papers
fifth fifth and they've gone up they've
gone up from 10th
in the past 10 years so so from all the
research that you've done
what else have you learned because you
know if if we if we truly want
i like one of the things you talk about
in your book if we truly want to
you know follow the percentage that
america is which is 60
caucasian you know 13 and a half percent
african-american you got whatever the
other percentages are
the nba should have a lot more hispanics
in there
they should in the nba a lot more asians
yeah you should have a lot more asians
in there why do you think the nba lacks
uh so of you know so many asian players
they get very good grades why wouldn't
nba focus on recruiting more asian
basketball
because there's a difference well
because the mba is a meritocracy
and that's what by the way produces the
best product
when you have a when you have a
competition it's a true meritocracy you
get
you get the best product i don't think
anybody would want the nba to
artificially reach
reach for more asians when the asians
don't deserve to be on the playing field
let me get this straight you're not
offended that the nba has no interest in
recruiting you
no that doesn't offend you that they
don't come and target you to make that
make you their point guard
no because i'm self-confident enough
that i know that i'm competent enough
that if i was treated on the basis of
merit
obviously i'm not going to get the
athletic
i'm not going to be a professional
athlete but i know that i'm competent
enough that
you know there are other opportunities
available for me
now if if we use the model that ivy
leagues use
would the ivy leagues call the nba races
for not being diverse enough
no because the ivy leagues have a narrow
definition of racism in order for it to
be racist it has to be power
plus privilege and so they define power
as white power
so if there's too many whites it's
racist but if they're too many black
americans it's fine
why is that i'm curious because they
believe that whites are the privileged
race
in america they're the powerful race
so it's only racist if it's the powerful
who are oppressing
the powerless according to who they are
the privileged race
according to critical race theorists
according to
you know critical race theory started at
harvard law school in the sixth in the
70s
and 90s yeah can you tell us about the
history that and obviously
we've we've had the uh others on that
i've spoken about that word this is kind
of a
uh they're indoctrinating also in the
military i had the former space force
commander who got fired
from his position for talking about
these things but elaborate a little bit
more when you say you know crt started
in the 70s with harvard
well in the 70s derek bell who's a
harvard law professor was the first
black professor at harvard
he created a department called critical
legal studies the purpose of critical
legal studies was to investigate
the way that that the the the way that
race
still plays a part in so-called
colorblind law is what he called it so
he's trying to sort of to show that our
laws are still racist
that that's what he was that's what he
was trying to do and then he had a bunch
of students who came in
um kimberly crenshaw mary matsuda
roberto unger they they developed
a a separate theory under him called
critical race theory
which is which basically asserts that
society in america
has a privilege has privileged races and
oppressed races
and our laws today still privileged the
privileged races
so you don't you don't think that some
of the laws in the 60s
were a bit racist no no the laws in the
60s were def okay we're definitely
racist but here's what a critical legal
studies person
please would say he would say
you would say the civil rights for
example the civil rights act of 1965
says the state will not discriminate on
the basis of race ethnicity
color skin national origin anything like
that a critical
legal studies person would look at that
law and he would say
that law is still racist because
that law who because that what that law
does
is um it's it's it's
it's saying that even even even
even though it says that the state
should not discriminate
um what it's doing is it's refining the
current structure of america where
whites are still at the top and blacks
are still at the bottom so
e that law is is a kind of it's a new
base it's a neutral law but it's not
really a neutral law because it's still
refining the current power structure
got it so you know today i had a guest
on last week comedian moz
and he said well you know i was having a
conversation with a friend of mine
talking about what's wrong with crt
what's wrong with teaching crt in school
you know we don't teach the history of
racism in school we should teach the
history of racism because it's not being
taught right now
and why are so many people worried about
this
what's your biggest concern with crt
being taught in school today
uh it's that it's mental hijacking you
have
so you have when you teach critical race
theory you're basically
telling a person to second guess himself
so if you're a white person your default
is i'm not a racist
and you aren't a racist but a critical
racist
race theorist would say actually you are
a racist even though you don't think you
are a racist you are a racist because
you're participating
in a racist structure and that the whole
idea of critical race theory is to get
the white person to admit that he is a
racist
once the white person admits that he's a
racist critical race theorists have all
the power
over that person they can get them to do
anything that they want you know for
equity
anti-racism you got to pay reparations
everything like that but the
but the central premise the first
concession that critical race theorists
are always going to
make a person say is that he is a racist
and and that that is a very very
damaging moral philosophy because if you
are trying to
put all of your effort into convincing
somebody that he's a racist even though
he's not a racist
um you're going to spend a lot of a lot
of energy
um basically deflating that person's
self-confidence and destroying their
their belief and their moral goodness in
themselves
do you think bad ideas can permanently
win
permanently yeah no
tell me why i because well because
there's
because we have a cycle of history um
there's a
there's a great quote uh
i forget who said it but he said um
hard times make strong men strong men
make good times
good times make weak men weak men make
hard times
it's a cycle of history right and and
right now we're in good times
but we're producing weak men and the
critical race theory
is one of those theories that is
producing weak men because it is
getting a person to second guess destroy
his self-confidence destroy his ego
that's the whole point of a critical
race so let's just say this continues
let's just say this continues and this
prophecy goes okay
give me the sequence first comes the crt
the white man agrees they
are what comes next and what happens at
the end if we know hard times produce
tough leaders
tough leaders produce good times good
times produce weak leaders weak leaders
produce tough times
if we know that's the formula how does
this go walk through walk us through the
sequencing and how it ends
okay well somebody told me a a a
conservative
scholar a very famous conservative
scholar once told me
that critical race theories objection
objective
obviously they want to destroy white
people but after that they want to
destroy black men
because the reason why they want to
destroy black men is because black men
still subscribe to this
you know sort of masculinity ideal um
that prevents that um and this
individualism this sort of rugged
individualism that critical race
theorists hate
so they're they're they're not cape they
don't want to live with um
with white people but then after that
they do they want to destroy the whole
concept of
an individual centered masculinity in
itself
and uh and and that's that's what i
think is gonna happen
you know once they go after the whites
once they successfully convince
whites that they're racist they're gonna
go after the truly individual
individualistic free-spirited black men
in this country
and they're going to convince them that
they are perpetuating something awful
why though what's the outcome what's the
ultimate outcome say they get everything
they want what's the ultimate outcome
the ultimate outcome is collectivization
under identity politics where the where
the winners
are the people who who claim that they
represent
the so-called identity group so if
you're
the what we're what we're what we're
going to
what we're going to in our culture right
now we're going from a culture where
merit
advances people and merit is rewarded to
towards a culture where victimhood is
rewarded where self-victimhood is
rewarded okay
so if you are um the people who will win
in this in a critical race theory
dominated society
are the people uh like kimberly crenshaw
the critical race theorists who claim
i stand for black people and who are and
i i stand
for asian people you know i am the
leader of this of this asian related
group
give me give my non-profit the money and
you see this already the after stop
asian hate happened after stop asian
hate happens billions of dollars went to
so-called
non-profits that advocated for asian
american causes but they're they did not
those asian-american causes did not go
to actual asian-american communities
they went to the leaders
they fattened themselves their paychecks
um and and that's what's happening in
their culture
you ever been discriminated you ever
felt it like if
like if i tell you mine you know in the
armenian community it's you you call the
folk
or a fob you know fresh off the boat or
you know a bunch of these things that
i've been called i was in the army
i told my drill sergeant and he says
what's your first name private i said
patrick he says you don't like look like
a patrick you look like a mohammed
and i'm like oh okay coley i've been
called that before but i'm a patrick you
know so did they change your name
i've had certain things that i've
experienced but to me
it's you know it was very normal when i
was coming up with that it's
very normal for somebody to call you
full when you're coming up did you
experience discrimination yourself
okay we this is this is another point of
my book and also with my larger advocacy
we're all discriminated against we're
always just people are
always discriminated okay when you're
going to a cashier
or a cash register and you're going to
i'll either
aisle 7 or aisle 8 and one cash register
is um you know a grumpy looking person
who just got a bad
hair day and another cash register is an
attractive woman
you know who are you gonna go to or who
you're more likely to go you're always
discriminated
so um that's the thing about our culture
like i was discriminated against
um in in the book for goodness sakes in
the in the book
publishing process because you know i
wasn't a household name
but i was almost also discriminated for
like my asian-ness helped me
in getting the contract from my book as
well it's impossible to control all of
the circumstances in which you are
never discriminated against for
something um
and so this is this is part of the the
advocacy that i'm showing is that we're
always discriminating um but what we can
do is we can try to treat people more
meritocratically
you know some people may disagree with
you and they may say
the grumpy old man will make for a
better conversation and a better story
than the dragon
you know but we know which one you're
going to go to but let's go back to that
so i asked you a question about the nba
and he said listen
because they're going to go after you
know whatever the you know
meritocracy you got to get the guy
that's going to outperform the other one
and you know so
a guy like me who's five with a six inch
vertical leap
is probably not a good uh you know uh
quality of guy to be in the nba but go
to nhl
if you go to the nhl what percent of it
nba i think is 75
76 african american nhl is more like
95 caucasian how come
the crt community or the harvard
community cannot
go how come you don't hear any uh
pushback with nhl
well i'm hearing a bit of pushback i
read and watched recent washington post
article
um you know complained about the
whiteness of the nhl players
no doubt but i think you know sports
fans largely respect meritocracy i think
this is like
why the reason why and the nhl hasn't
been the subject
of as huge of a pushback as say
um you know the political sphere is
because we largely respect the fact we
largely respect the system
that produces and then rewards the best
athletes
i agree with you i'm just wondering how
come nhl has a gun in it sometimes i
wonder because they're worried because
these nhl guys would whoop their asses
because you do not want to fight nhl
players they're
they're probably the toughest athletes
out of all sports they uh
if you've ever gone to a bar fight with
an nhl player it usually doesn't end too
well for you but now let's go back to
completed
here's another side so okay uh uh the
the
the the the skill of lying
on your uh application to be accepted
into a college
right so there is benefits to elizabeth
warren saying
i am uh native american indian right so
you know and then they do the testing
just a few years ago and it shows
i don't remember what number was one in
1004 she is
native american and you know it was like
uh everybody was talking about it you're
not
use it to get into colleges so
does it benefit an asian to not put
themselves as asian
and put themselves as something else on
the job application to be accepted to
one of these ivy league schools
no and i'm going to set the record
straight on this
doesn't matter if you check or uncheck
your box asian or not
doesn't matter harvard's going to know
what race you are the reason why is
because they do data mining
they know who you are they they have
consulting
agencies that know everything about you
not everything but they know a lot of
things about your background such as
your race
your parents family income the
neighborhood you grew up in the crime
rate of your neighborhood
all those kinds of things so don't don't
don't um don't assume that these harvard
people don't have their data and their
smarts
and their wits about them they're gonna
they know
maybe you would also need to change your
last name right and you would probably
also i mean if you want to really
disguise it i mean
you could change your last name not
everybody does it like harvard but
harvard's gonna know your race
unless of course you're uh uh you're
elizabeth warren
and you come off as a perfectly white
passing person but you claim your 132nd
cherokee i don't think harvard's gonna
know that so maybe they'll they'll give
her the benefit of the doubt there
she's got a gift though you got to give
her i mean you got to give credit to her
gift her ability to
you know convince the world that she's a
native american indian because uh
that is a gift of hers but uh not
forever
it's true that's why i'm saying bad
ideas you know my ideas bad ideas don't
live forever they just full of p
full of few people sometimes a few
million people for a few decades and
then they realize it was a shitty idea
and typically
by the time they find that it's a bad
idea it's already too late you only got
a few more years to live my hopes are
that people
like us you know i told you off camera i
said isn't it weird that we got a
guy who's from china second generation
you yourself and said second generation
i think you said second generation
and you got someone here who lived in
iran ten years
two years in germany and uh how do you
feel about what america was founded on
what does this idea of america mean to
you because to me
i think this is the greatest country in
the world what do you think about
american how it was founded on
america is a country
that to me at its best it judges you
on the content of your character not the
color of your skin that is a founding
american principle i know it wasn't
articulated by thomas jefferson or
martin luther it was articulated by
martin luther king excuse me
um but it is a founding american
principle it is the principle that has
made this country so great because we
are such an accepted country because we
accept immigrants
and not just that we accept immigrants
but we say to them
you're not guaranteed success in this
country
but if you work hard you'll be treated
on the basis of that work
not your background that's the ideal
that has made america great
it's the american dream it's the
foundation of meritocracy
and that's why america is the greatest
country in the world why why does that
concept scare so many people
you know why does the concept of knowing
the fact that
you know like when i was coming up i had
a 1.8
slightly lower than yours and with a gpa
like 1.8
you know community colleges turn you
down you know you you're not even they
you know if you just want to go to local
starbucks they turn you down because
your your gpa is so low so
i don't have a lot of options so i was
the kid that they said this guy's not
gonna amount to a lot and you know a lot
of my peers went to different places
fast forward i got out of the military
and i love what you say about military
because i think
uh i was looking at statistics earlier
do you know more african-american women
join the military than african-american
men
it's it's and it's by eight percent
higher that more african-american women
join uh the uh of the of the women in
the military
29 i think are uh women
african-american women of the men i
think 20
of the men are african-american in the
military it's very high number
but you said something about you know
sometimes you have folks who are
african-american who join the military
they come out they typically do better
in their careers and their businesses
because of what's taught so i went to
the military i was somebody that wasn't
uh projected to do something big with my
life i learned some discipline came out
applied it in the world of business and
it kind of helped me out
but why do you think this concept of
saying yeah but
listen kenny you're asian you're smart
your genetics you can't think everybody
has the privileges that you have
you're able to get whatever you want
because you're smarter than everybody
else well patrick
you're the exception to the rule you
know you made it because you are the
exception
that doesn't mean everybody else can
make it what do you say when people say
you know your exception to the rule most
people do not have
the ability to have their dreams come
true in america anymore like they once
used to
there are people that exist anymore so
people are definitely born into unequal
privilege in society that's that's 100
correct the issue at hand is not
can we make everybody who is unequally
privileged or who is unequally
privileged equally privileged
that would just be socialism the issue
is can we provide enough opportunity
for the people who are less privileged
to be able to succeed in this country if
they
really desire to and my answer to that
is definitively yes we have a lot of
structures
in our country they need work but that
enable you to really
achieve the american dream for example
the military just like what you said
just like what you said
black men and black people who join the
military have
higher much higher career outcomes
business careers they graduate higher
rates of education
and if you build in that structure into
these people's lives
and some of these people are coming from
homes in which there wasn't structure
but you build in that sort of structure
in a person's life and it is going to
change their life it's going to make
them
a lot more successful and that's just
one of the structures that we have in
this country
now one of the structures that we have
in this country that is actually hurting
a lot of black and hispanic americans is
the welfare state
is the welfare state this sort of no no
questions
asked we're going to give you money kind
of
kind of philosophy is really hurting a
lot of people now you have people
advocating for a
universal basic income we're going to
give you money no matter how hard you
work or anything like that
that instills the wrong mindset in
people so that's actually causing people
to um
to to to really uh stay in the position
that they're in and be incentivized to
stay in the position that they're in
rather than get out
now when you say ubi you've got to be
careful there because the person that
talked about ubi a lot is a man who is
from taiwan
and you know his name is andrew yang and
so
you know it you know that may be a
friend of yours who
you know got that message and as an
entrepreneur he got
millions of people to buy into the
concept of universal basic income
but you don't you don't agree with ubi
no
no and and and here's why one
it's going to cause inflation we've
already seen like a form of ubi be
passed
in during the coveted pandemic yeah you
know and guess what
food prices are like 30 40 percent
higher now gas prices are higher
home prices are higher and that that's
causing inflation so inflation is going
to be higher but forget just the
economics
of it think about the the the
disincentivization of personal
responsibility that ubi creates
kenny your parents left china to come
here it's not your parents your
grandparents left china to come to your
second generation
or do your parents who who left china to
come here parents or grandparents
my parents your parents why did they
what was their reasoning to leave china
to come to america
because my dad he was you study at fudon
university
um you know back in back in the day
china was just opening up but it was
poor
it was poor it did not have prosperity
america had a lot of prosperity
and america had a lot of freedom my dad
was actually politically involved
um not at like the communist party level
he was never recruited for that
but he he for example was like a whole
um was like a class leader like class
president that kind of thing
he was always an outspoken person and he
realized he'd become a little too
outspoken
in you know china not not so not so good
not so good so he valued both america's
prosperity
and america's penchant for freedom
do you guys still have family in china
that your parents communicate with or no
we do we do we do we have we have a lot
of family there yeah what what do they
say about the conditions in china today
are they supportive of it are they
saying well look guys it's not the same
thing as it was when you left when they
talked to your dad
it's changed a lot it's a much better
place what is their impression of what
china's like today
so china is a lot better uh there's the
china
by and large you can't deny china has
improved
middle class life for a lot of their
citizens in
massive massive ways now that they do it
through cheating do they do it through
intellectual property stealing of
american things
uh yeah to some extent but also they did
open up their economy you know their
economy was basically
maoist you know maoism a sort of forced
agrarianism where people had to
redistribute wealth
is not exactly the best way to create
prosperity but when deng xiaoping in
the 1980s opened china up and said okay
we're going to allow manufacturing
we're going to allow um foreign trade
international trade
um and he came up with capitalism with
chinese characteristics which is what
it's called there
uh yeah the country did experience you
know great prosperity so it is doing a
lot better you know in shanghai right
now it's more expensive
an apartment in shanghai is more
expensive than an apartment in new york
would you would you go back and live in
china if you could
no no i was
the one the funny thing is i look like a
chinese
american here in america but if i went
to china
i wouldn't even have to speak people
would know i'm american
why is that because of my walk because
of my teeth
because um of of my
cadence it's it's it's a feeling it's a
feeling
this is this is something that people
understand about america they think that
everybody who comes to america just
represents their home country no we
actually
you know if you live in america long
enough you were born here you were
raised here
in in many ways you you become an
american
uh are you are you someone that's
worried about the direction china is
going right now and the amount of
concentration they have in america
today uh like the amount of like
influence and poor foreign influence to
have in america
sure sure of course i'm worried about
their i'm worried about
foreign influence in america in general
you know in china to the extent that
they have spies intelligence in america
you know that obviously needs to be shut
out
um particularly with regards to currency
manipulation
trade everything like that i think that
that that needs to be a policy that's
handled by better experts than me on
that
so what's what's long-term aspirations
for someone like you wha
what do you want to do next i know you
were working with
young americans foundation you're uh
serving currently
as their development officer i know
you're writing books that are again the
attentions of a lot of people what what
are your long-term
aspirations why i left with young
america's foundation i love young
america's foundation by the way but i i
did come to serve
i was recruited as president of colorist
united which is behind me right here
where we advocate for a race-blind
america race blind
america you know coloristunited.org
and we're basically doing institutional
guerrilla warfare patrick because
so many of these institutions have
resorted to treating people on the basis
of identities that are practically
speaking
um uh collectivists and irrelevant to
them
um so if your listeners really agree
with
you know the subject of what i'm talking
about and how we can fight for a truly
race-blind america
should go to colorestunited.org but
that's really what i am
and and sign our petition uh because
that's that's really what i'm working on
working on creating a more just and more
meritocratic society we're gonna put the
link below for people to go to your
website uh and
for people to be able to find you as
well whether it's twitter on this or
instagram we'll put those as well
also the link to your inconvenient truth
do you run a podcast by the way do you
have a podcast or a youtube channel that
you run
inconvenient minority with kenny shu
where i tackle race identity and culture
i've had james lindsay chris ruffo on
board
uh heather mcdonald is one person who i
correspond regularly with who i have on
the podcast
so just search inconvenient minority
with kenny shu you can find it wherever
podcasts are
i got a i got a recommendation for you
for someone to interview his name is
lucia
prescott lucian truscott
lucian trust god if you google him he is
this a great great great uh
grandson of thomas jefferson and i think
i would love to see you interview him it
would be very entertaining and if you
don't know who he is if you google his
name on if you search his name on
youtube
you'll see an interview with him and i
and after about one minute you'll know
why i'm recommending you to
sit down with them i think it'll be
entertaining i think people will love it
but i think the chances of agreeing for
an interview with you is less than one
tenth of a percent
so hey buddy uh very excited about what
you're doing keep doing what you're
doing it's very necessary the the
the concept of bringing awareness to
this topic from the angle that you're
taking it and having the moral authority
to share with your background is
extremely helpful gets a lot of us
thinking
but it's been very nice to have you on
here on valuetainment
absolutely patrick thank you for having
me anytime take care
what do you have to say about what he
said bob what are your thoughts i mean
he had a lot of things to say pretty
eloquent uh
speaker so comment below i'm curious if
you enjoyed it put a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel
i got two other interviews i want you to
watch if you enjoyed this one of them is
not an interview a video i did a few
years ago titled every university's
worst
nightmare if you've never seen it click
over here and the other one is with the
former space force commander who got
fired because he shared what's really
taking place in the military u.s
military
similar to what kenny is saying taking
place with ivy league schools having
said that
enjoy take care everybody